I had a Seth Stevens davidowitz on the
show and don't trust your gut he did a
data scientists approach to optimizing
his personal appearance and he split
tested put a photo of him with a beard
up did I get a beard should I have
glasses should I have my hair short
should I have my hair long should I wear
this should I wear that and he basically
split tested all of the different
iterations of his appearance down to I
should have a beard wear glasses this
particular like collection of things he
is now by his own admission in a
relationship with a girl that he's
punching out of his league with and the
reason that that happened he said and he
has data to back this up you want to try
and make people love or hate sort of
luck that you have going forward you
don't want to be everybody's just okay
and advice for guys in dating sticking
to some of the absolute undeniable rules
and then going okay what am I what am I
really really good at if you're really
really good at being the The Artsy guy
with a hanging earring that can play the
guitar like yo lean into being Mr guitar
player thing or if you're the super
funny guy you know Pete Davidson to the
root to go whatever it might be you can
become more of what you are